les britanniques par référendum ont
décidé de quitter l'union européenne
c'est un choix douloureux et je le
regrette profondément
pour le royaume uni et pour l'europe
mais ce choix est le leur et nous devons
le respecter
on en tirant toutes les conséquences
la grande bretagne ne fera donc plus
partie de l'union européenne et les
procédures prévues par les traités
seront rapidement appliquées
c'est la règle et c'est la conséquence
la france pour elle même et pour la
grande-bretagne continuera à travailler
avec ce grand pays ami auquel l'histoire
et la géographie nous unissent par tant
de liens sur le plan économique humain
culturel et je n'oublie pas nos
relations étroites en matière de défense
qui seront préservés le vote des
britanniques mais gravement l'europe à
l'épreuve
elle doit montrer dans ces circonstances
sa solidité et sa force en apportant les
réponses nécessaires pour maîtriser les
risques économiques et financiers du
départ du royaume uni des mesures sont
d'ores et déjà prises et j'ai confiance
dans leur efficacité
mais la décision britannique exige aussi
de prendre lucidement conscience des
insuffisances du fonctionnement de
l'europe et de la perte de confiance des
peuples dans le projet qu'elle porte le
danger est immense face aux extrémismes
et au populisme
il faut toujours moins de temps pour
défaire que pour faire pour détruire que
pour construire la france pays
fondateurs de l'europe ne l'acceptera
pas un sursaut est nécessaire l'europe
pour aller de l'avant
ne peut plus faire comme avant les
peuples attendent de l'union européenne
qu'elle réaffirme ses valeurs valeurs de
liberté de tolérance et de paix l'europe
doit donc être une puissance qui décide
souverainement de son destin et qui
revendique son modèle la france sera
donc à l'initiative pour que l'europe se
concentre sur l'essentiel la sécurité et
la défense de notre continent pour
protéger nos frontières et pour
préserver la paix face aux menaces
l'investissement pour la croissance et
pour l'emploi coe mettre en oeuvre des
politiques industrielles dans le domaine
des nouvelles technologies et de la
transition énergétique
l'harmonisation fiscale et sociale pour
donner à nos économies des règles et à
nos concitoyens des garanties enfin le
renforcement de la zone euro et de sa
gouvernance démocratique
l'europe et c'est ma conviction doit
porter des projets et non pas se perdre
en procédure elle doit être comprise et
contrôlés par les citoyens elle doit
décider vite là on l'attend et laisser
une fois pour toutes aux états nations
ce qui relève de leurs seules
compétences
c'est le mandat que j'irai porté au
conseil européen mardi prochain je
rencontrerai au préalable les
responsables politiques des grandes
formations de notre pays j'irai
également lundi à berlin pour que avec
la chancelière merkel est sans doute
avec matteo renzi nous puissions
également évoqué ce qui doit être fait
notamment pour la préparation de ce
conseil
l'allemagne parce que de notre unité
dépend la cohésion de l'ensemble de
l'union européenne l'europe
est une grande idée est pas seulement un
grand marché c'est sans doute à force de
l'avoir oublié qu'elle s'est perdu
l'europe doit continuer à être un espoir
pour la jeunesse car c'est son horizon
aujourd'hui c'est l'histoire qui frappe
à notre porte
ce qui se joue c'est la dilution de
l'europe au risque du repli ou la
réaffirmation de son existence au prix
de changements profonds
je ferai tout pour que ce soit le
changement profond plutôt que le repli
et la france a une responsabilité
particulière parce qu'elle est au coeur
de l'europe parce qu'elle a voulu
l'europe
pascal a bâti l'europe parce qu'elle est
le pays qui peut entraîner les autres et
qui est garant de l'avenir de notre
continent
c'est ma conviction de français et
d'européens et c'est ce qui me
déterminera dans la conduite de l'autre
pays dans cette période si décisive mais
dont nous savons que l'histoire
aujourd'hui nous juge puisque l'histoire
est là soyons à la hauteur de la
circonstance que nous traversons merci